so uh I have this here from Wikipedia
the list of speakers 1923 check this out
Progressive Republicans had refused to
support Gillette for the first eight
ballots only after winning concessions
from Republican conference leaders a
seat in the house rules committee and a
pledge that requested house rules change
would be considered did they agree to
support him this was the first
speakership election to take multiple
bouts since the Civil War and then we
have this from The Washington Post check
this out
when the house needed two months and 133
votes to elect a speaker
okay
they say you know goes back to 1856 it
was a crazy election took months
let's let's hope that we resolve this
house stuff tomorrow
because if it ends up taking eight votes
and then finally there's concessions
made and maybe Kevin McCarthy gives more
concessions to say Matt Gates loan
bobert et cetera enough that they
actually will be able to do real
investigations or something like that
it's better than taking two months and
uh being more indicative of a coming
civil war or something you know what
would be a scenario if there was no
speaker
well there would be no new member sworn
in you wouldn't be able to vote on
anything else until there's a speaker in
office so it would literally put the
entire Branch
um at a standstill rather than the
Senate they were sworn in today but so
they couldn't even vote on things if
there's no speaker I like that idea that
sounds great that sounds awesome and you
only need five people yeah five people
man shut down Congress let's do it yeah
how did but how did Thomas Massey vote
did he vote for McCarthy I'm not sure
I wonder I'm not sure if he was one of
the defectors or not I don't think some
people people were telling me not to
call the voters defectors the people
voting for Jim Jordan are the people's
vote and the rest are the shill votes I
want to stress this all right
the people who are voting before
McCarthy are just doing it because
McCarthy's The Machine he's the
Republican machine and when the machine
comes to you and they control funds and
they can Crush you they say look you
vote for me we'll get you the Committees
you want that's the way it's played
don't f with me and they go yeah yeah
for sure no problem now you've got
people who are like I don't care
Matt Gates is like I don't care I'm not
going to vote for it's not going to
happen Lauren Barber says the same thing
this is the I am a Spartacus moment this
is where people the Republicans can now
stand up safely and say look I don't
want to cause any problems but you guys
don't have it I'm gonna vote for Jim
Jordan yeah they need to do it yeah
and it's that type of moral courage and
conviction that we need right now if
we're actually going to have the
investigations that really matter like
you said looking into all this fouchy
related stuff looking into the Twitter
files and big Tech collusion with the
federal government we don't do that by
having someone who has already showed us
who they are like literally believe
someone the first time when they show
you who they are when is McCarthy in his
history as you know a member of
leadership ever really been the guy to
you know burn down the barn and say
we're going to get to the bottom of this
and figure out what exactly is going on
um Jim Jordan has showed us who he is
um you know there are other options out
there who have shown us who they are and
I think that like when you have those
options especially when the fact that we
don't control the Senate and the
Democrats and the left will still
control the White House for several
years to come so it's like we are the
opposition party all we can really do is
investigate and hold people accountable
and if we don't have a speaker as able
and willing to do that then what are we
even doing what are we wasting our time
on what I also just like the Revenge
element of it yeah like it was just
funny to watch Kevin McCarthy lose three
times in historical failure because he's
he's been a never Trumper he's been he's
look man they're a handful I'm not a
republican I keep saying a million times
never cared for the Republican party but
then all of a sudden and I was even late
to the party too like I I they were they
were former Occupy Wall Street people
nine million Obama voters switched to
vote for Trump and I was like I'm not
voting for Trump then I start seeing
what Trump is doing I see these people
who used to be Bernie supporters now
voting for Trump and I was like wow like
I didn't even realize that and then
people were like look he wants to bring
jobs back to this country he wants to
secure our border he wants to end
Foreign Wars and I'm like you know those
are really good points like I didn't
take Trump seriously in in the beginning
I probably should have should I probably
should have at least you know but I was
just so jaded so this time around okay
I'm gonna vote for the guy
does Kevin McCarthy and and you know
even with all due respect Marjorie
Taylor green think that someone like me
would actually get behind a guy who
claimed Putin was you know that you know
the Russia pushed the Russia collusion
nonsense or the January 6th nonsense I'm
not interested in that yeah that that's
you you will never see me be like a
proud party Republican who's gonna March
in lockstep with Republican
establishment because I'm supposed to
not interested in that according to
oxios Thomas Macy is voting for Kevin
McCarthy yeah that's what I figured I
figured uh I'd like to see Massey a
speaker of the house that'd be great
he'd probably just like could you
imagine if Ron Paul was speaker
just I'm not gonna swear anybody in yeah
we're just we're just we're just it did
a real job a young man honestly stopped
Thomas Massey would be a great speaker
of the house because he's kind of like a
robot I mean I love you Tom obviously
with like uh like autistic robot you
know you got the engineering skills down
if you know what I'm saying man we need
someone that's that's impartial that's
willing to just work off of facts and
logic if they're gonna function as a as
the speaker for the whole you don't want
the emotions clouding it up here's ears
and you're not a robot bro you're a man
let's let's let's let's go back to the
core of this this segment right so it
was 1856 just before the Civil War when
tensions are as hot as they've ever been
and it took months to finally get a
speaker then of course a few months a
few years later they're in Civil War
then you get 1923. so I suppose my view
is I know Luke you're saying gridlock is
good and I'm like yes gridlock's
preferable to corruption but I want a
net positive I want investigations so I
guess my concern is
what's what's the what's the risk of
destabilization if we go for hard
investigations and accountability versus
letting the machine lock itself down and
then just having nothing happen right
like which is what is the preferable
scenario yeah you could accidentally
uncover a lot of stuff that makes people
very angry very riotous and then you
have foreign corporations come in be
like you're the victim here the American
government was out to get you we'll
protect you I'm Klaus Schwab I'm here to
help and uh then all of a sudden we have
a corporate State the foreign
corporations have already taken over the
public government in they already they
already are in charge they already are
crawling the shot so we look at our form
of government They don't serve the
people there there's been many studies
particularly showing populist the
policies never get passed the lot of the
policies that the lobbyists want past
they get passed especially when they
have big money behind them so that that
what you're warning about happening
already has happened well so but look my
question for you is do you think it's
better to have investigations like a
church commission or gridlock shutting
the government down investing
allegations or whitewashes that's
another no I know let's let's say we
could get let's say Jim Jordan wins and
he actually says okay we're gonna have
some accountability maybe not perfect
but it's going to be it's not gonna be a
white wash so is that good or would you
rather see gridlock I'd rather see
gridlock because it's going to be the
same government that just a couple days
ago passed the 1.7 trillion dollar
spending bill it's going to be the same
government that just passed Bill Gates's
inflation reduction act which doesn't
really uh reduce or do anything with
inflation it's the same people
predominantly in power right now that
are going to be doing more with your
life and I just have I just I just don't
believe them when they're going to come
here and say we're going to do things
differently now I mean really come on I
agree like that's the thing too like a
lot of people are saying Jim Jordan and
I'm kind of you know I I guess maybe I
mean I've seen it I've seen him write a
lot of letters I've seen him speak up a
whole lot it's better than nothing but I
don't know if I've seen enough to where
I'm like you he's the guy like Thomas
Massey is someone where I I trust him
that if he was speaker you you'd
actually see something happen I don't
know about Jim Jordan that's why I
probably agree with you more Luke my
view is your option the options and the
speaker vote today were control or
controlled opposition that's why I'm
just like not interested yeah what's
your what's your vision I think that's a
lot of people right now but I think when
you talk about is it worth the trouble I
think the people want the trouble they
want to see these investigations they
want to see these these truths uncovered
wherever that may lead and I think that
it's so easy to get trout of the
personality debate when it comes to this
because we're dealing with people do you
really like McCarthy do you really like
Jim Jordan those are all personality
questions but I think at the end of the
day what we are seeing from if you just
look at Twitter and the conversation
that's going on about it every single
tweet that Marjorie dealer green has
made uh you know super Manning for Kevin
McCarthy has been ratioed every single
oh yeah and it's just like the people
want accountability and we're not going
to get that by being the complacent
conservative movement that we've always
been I was I was watching War Room
earlier and marjor Taylor green appeared
on it and so I'm like I gotta see this
because you know look I like Marjorie
and I want to I want to hear what she
has to say about Kevin McCarthy and yo
the chat lit up with shill sell out
you've turned you've abandoned us
backstabber they are not happy with
Margaret Taylor green on this one it's
worth hearing her out of course before
you start judging the person she's not
wrong in the sense that she has a logic
to her decision Kevin McCarthy is the
leadership he's made concessions on
certain things he said there will be
investigations and she's probably been
guaranteed committee positions where she
who I trust would actually do something
will do something
but I'm just going to come out and say
it like
Marjorie is a republican she's a trump
Republican but she's still going to be
there for the party yeah don't look at
me like I was barely there I wasn't
there at all in 2016 I was barely there
in 2020. and I think that's the problem
Republicans barely squeaked by because
they were able to convince a lot of
post-liberals moderates and you know
like like more middle of the road people
to support them now they're coming out
and saying it's it's here's how I feel I
don't want to speak for anybody else I
feel like now that they've won they're
coming to people like me and being like
okay now that you've helped us fall in
line here's our Republican establishment
plan I'm like bro don't look at me
you're not going to convince me to
anything you're lucky you got my vote in
the first place yeah so I just I just I
don't see it man you should always be
reticent about voting for quote the
party that's a big Hitler attack you
know Hitler wrote about the party in
mineconf it's all about the party
putting the party first you know it's do
not do that in America I mean oh geez
vote you know here's you know here's
what we need we need an Elon Musk in
Congress and I don't mean Elon Musk
literally I mean someone who's willing
to stake 40 billion dollars to do
something kind of Off the Wall kind of
nuts I would like to see Matt Gates
stand up and nominate Donald Trump he
should he should get up there he should
be like I am nominating Donald Trump for
Speaker of the House
he is a great leader he has massive uh
you know support along the base there
you go but could Donald Trump even get
the votes at this point right who cares
that's the thing like someone needs to
throw a figurative pie yeah like Jim
Jordan is not a pie Jim Jordan is a
middle finger to McCarthy so he can't
win but come on like Biggs was was not
bad you know Freedom caucus guy but they
they could they could have still done
better you know I mean even even Matt
Gates nominating Lauren bobert would
have been better yeah okay you know
whatever who should it be luke uh Ron
Paul
Dr no they call them that in the
Congress because he would vote no on
everything see like we need that kind of
leadership so here's a question like why
doesn't Thomas Massey do it maybe
because he's more robotic and he's more
like you know it's not worth it because
no one nominated him is that the only
reason yeah if I was if I was in
Congress it would be it would be I'd be
the craziest person in Congress people
would be like this dude's out of his
mind I'd stand up and I'd say Ron Paul
you'd be the AOC of the right no I yeah
you would no AOC fine line fell in line
behind Nancy Pelosi she got whip crack
and she was like whatever you say Pelosi
what do you think
Ron Paul and I'll be like look I don't
agree with Ron Paul a lot of things he's
you know he's a right libertarian kind
of guy but I agree with him on one thing
he promised to leave me alone if the
government has a guy in there who's like
here's my policy positions like okay I
don't like all of those but I also
promise first and foremost to leave you
alone I'll be accountable for you yeah
so I if I was me I just I I'd throw a
figurative pie I'd be like can we
nominate Thomas Massey there's 45
000 people listening right now you guys
want to nominate Massey let's do it
Thomas you got my nomination yeah but I
think the thing that like makes him not
want it is also a part of his virtue
like Thomas he just wants to go up there
fight for America fight for limited
government he's not at all really
concerned about the power and that is
just oftentimes like the conflict of
politics that everyone that we want to
run never runs because they're smart
enough to know not to and I think that
like why would you actually want to be
Speaker of the House sure you could do a
lot of good work but like why would you
put yourself in that position
um can we get Michael someone someone
said Michael Mouse for speaker Andre
Super Chat I'm like how about we just
can he run for Congress uh yeah you know
just yes
you know him just being in there would
be hilarious let's break down I think
someone like Jeffrey Dahmer would be
more of a perfect fan in Congress when
you look at his activities they match up
with what Congress is doing you know
that pretty well as a member of the
black bean I don't know if I can endorse
that and then I'd be safe for us
um you know no but but hold on there on
that thought
there have been I've heard people talk
about
sending like like having people like
Dahmer murderers people with Criminal
Intent into the military into foreign
conflict uh intentionally they look for
these people because they want combat
yeah imagine if if you took all the
serial killers in the United States
instead of impressing them we're like
we're gonna unleash you on our enemies
that's like Starcraft is how they do
yeah blizzard they put guys inside of
Mech suits permanently forever as that's
their prison and then they have to fight
in the Mexicans that's taikus he's one
of them well okay yeah I don't know
let's turn on their turn on their
captors what's our resolution to this
historic moment what do you guys think
before we move on well what's the
speaker of the house what's the purpose
of the role it's it's third in line for
the presidency all right they're they
basically are the highest position in
Congress in in the house and so they
sent committees they they decide when
bills go to the floor things like that
is it they the one person sets every
committee I I don't know exactly it's
through the house during committee but
the speaker basically controls his
appointment so by extension the speaker
yeah it makes sense okay can the speaker
overrule the point committee is that
what's called they can they can change
the rules of the session of the Congress
it's a very powerful position in
government yeah someone joke someone
joked that um the the the concession for
like Matt Gates and bobert and all them
they should tell Kevin McCarthy new rule
for the for for the 118th Congress that
Democrats don't get to vote
you could make any like you could make
up weird rules I don't know how weird
you can get but uh like Papa John's for
dinner on Thursdays they could do that
kind of stuff I mean that'd be that'd be
cool I I would just I'd love to I'm
thinking about it I'm like man
I wish I could be there I I would never
want to be in politics it's awful but
just for that one moment to stand up and
nominate Donald Trump would be totally
worth it or nominate someone like Dave
Smith wouldn't that be just amazing if
somebody just got up and said Dave Smith
he's a funny guy libertarian let's have
him do it
that'd be great yeah just just to say it
so on everyone everyone watching on
C-Span or whatever here's you say it the
most interesting thing on season in a
while all right so this is gonna happen
tomorrow they're coming back at noon
there's probably another vote
right now I bet every single one of
these people they're on the phone
non-stop you've got threats probably and
threats aren't going to work you know
Matt Gates came out and said they
threatened to take away our committee
positions don't care you're not gonna
you're not gonna win this one against
Matt Gates by going in there and
spitting on him and threatening him
you've gotta you're not gonna get it
unless you unless you give a little bit
and where was this energy towards Elon
Omar right what everything that she said
that was anti-semitic and all of these
things they have done more to criticize
internal dissent even going the length
of saying we're gonna take your
committee away but where was this energy
towards Elan Omar Rasheeda Talib it's
like insane it's like they want to crack
the whip on our own side but yet we can
never focus on the common enemy and hold
the left to the same account that we're
trying to do to ourselves because people
like McCarthy keep winning there's three
and it's because so many of these
Republicans are scared to go up against
the Republican establishment because of
things like what happened to Blake
Masters it's there's three parties in
Congress right now it's Democrat
Republican in this new party that's
still Republican Maga yeah whatever you
want Maga whatever the lion got
energized Trump elephant donkey lion
yeah there really is and I think that's
where all this divisiveness is coming
from is the two political parties within
the Republican party which for whatever
reason they haven't started a new party
yet well you know what um um we'll we'll
see what happens I'm I'm I'm tired of
the same old same old so I'm not
interested in voting for these people
just so that they can come look
Donald Trump is what convinces me and
and Maga and all that stuff to vote for
it they oppose the The Grooming of the
kids stuff the CRT Foreign Wars stronger
borders all like they support stronger
boards I'm for those things I am not for
14-year establishment Republicans who
are Democrats go on the speed limit I
just I'm not for that thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time